what do you think about my business idea
a lot of entrepreneurs write in to me
and they ask me that what do you think
about my idea is this a good idea should
I go for this or not they need
validation you want someone to tell you
hey this is great do it here's the
problem I can't tell you if you have a
good business idea or not it has to come
from your heart as black and white and
as kind of numbers basis business is the
real successful businesses come from an
entrepreneur who has a passionate belief
in what they're doing they see a need in
this world and they go out and they fill
it and it doesn't matter what the
numbers say at the start doesn't matter
what your market research tells you at
the beginning because people have gone
into businesses that look terrible like
why would you go into that business
there's no money to be made and they
become ultra successful and people have
gone into industries that look fantastic
and have failed miserably because of the
only reason you're going to go into a
business is to make money or because the
market trends say hey this is a hot
industry you're not going to make it the
number one most important rule for
starting a business is having passion
for it you have to have a deep passion
for what you're doing and if you do that
your business has the best chance of
being successful all the other rules in
business they don't apply they can't
help you if you're not passionate about
your company doesn't matter what your
marketing strategy is doesn't matter how
much financing you raise doesn't matter
about your human resources strategy it's
not gonna work your business will not
work unless you have that burning
passion I got a question from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys Muhammad
so Muhammad says what would you say on
starting the trade on authentic Islamic
books seems like the demand is really
low low margins can be charged in books
but it's something I really believe in
and you wanted my advice and what to do
so my answer is the same you know so I'm
not I'm not Islamic
I don't we use a Macbook s-- but as
fired nothing against it and even though
the man might be low and your margins
might be low the key part here is it's
something I really believe in and if
Muhammad you will
believe that these books are important I
need to be spread need to be out there
then you've got to do it you've got to
pour yourself into it and you can find a
way to be highly successful in it you
can find a way to make this business
take off but you've got to do something
a little different you've got to inject
yourself into the business you've got to
do it in a way that nobody has done it
before and if you're passionate about if
you love doing it if you're doing this
for a reason a deep meaningful purpose
then you're gonna find creative new ways
to grow this business even though it
looks completely unattractive at the
start even if a banker looked at this
and said why would you go to this
business there's no demand
there's no margins you're not gonna make
it even though it may not look good on
paper you can make it work if you bring
your passion creativity and personal
perseverance to the business and it
doesn't matter what the business is for
anybody has the same question I don't
care if you're selling Islamic books I
don't keep your selling tables I don't
care if you're trying to sell a sports
franchise I don't care if you're selling
cars whatever it is it doesn't matter
the business the product the service it
does not matter the thing that matters
is your belief in what you're doing
I believe in helping entrepreneurs it's
hard to make money helping entrepreneurs
entrepreneur's don't have money to spend
I'm going after the audience with like
the least amount of money to spend great
entrepreneurs have no money we're
spending everything on our business so
what the heck am i doing I've been going
out trying to help entrepreneurs I do it
to do it I do it because I love it I do
it because it's the right thing to do
because it fuels me gets me excited and
I found a different way to do it and as
a result I make money doing it even
though people might have said at the
start you're crazy
look this is stupid why don't just go
get a job or start a business where all
the trends are are going up and where
you have people who are making tons of
money who can buy from you
so it doesn't matter what your product
is or your service what matters is your
belief that you're doing the right thing
belief for those of you watching like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below it makes you want to do more for
you and I'd love to hear you two think
please leave a comment underneath let me
know what you think about the video you
have a question put it below I'll make a
video response
whew just like I did today from Mohammed
thank you so much and I'll see you soon